there's the history being made by dylan
lee who did not find out about this
start until today even though the braves
made the decision last night brian
snicker did not want him staying up all
night receiving texts and phone calls
you know a guy that's been used to
coming in out of the bullpen it seemed
weird seeing him coming out from the
outfield but that's what he's
comfortable doing i'd like to move by
brian snicker and dylan lee delivers the
first pitch of game four and altuve
grounds it left side deep in the hole
backhanded by swanson long throw to
first stretch by freeman and he came off
the bag altuve is saved as altuve raced
by swanson to his backhand had to get
rid of it as quickly as he could
couldn't get a whole lot on it an
inauspicious start for dylan lee still
two men on but now one out for jordan
alvarez inside and high ball four
so the bases are loaded one down here
comes brian snicker that might be it for
dylan lee very unfamiliar spot for a
reliever who spent most of his time in
triple a and now the ball goes to a
starter who enters a world series game
with the bases loaded and just one out
in the first and carlos correa the
batter correa bounces it softly left
side cutting across riley he fields
throws to first in time to get correa a
run comes home as altuve scores and it
is one to nothing astros as soon as he
hit it you knew it wasn't going to be a
double play it was hit too softly
so the astros are able to get on the
board first and you look at the other
games this postseason the teams that
have scored first in the other 34 games
those teams are 27 and seven zach cranky
would like to give this team multiple
innings
not just because he's out to try and win
a ball game be because then he loves to
hit and he's in the eighth spot so he
wants to get through a few at least so
two out in freeman still at first for
austin reilly right-handed hitting third
base
and that's lifted in the center tucker
coming in over toward right center makes
the catch and the inning is over tucker
was shaded toward right center against
the right-handed hitter riley braves get
a one-out hit but that's all and after
one astros one craves nothing so one out
and nobody on for zach cranky frankie
batting eighth tonight with maldonado
hitting ninth and grinky bounces it up
the middle and past the dive of all bees
in the center a base hit for zach
ranking how do you like that frankie
gets himself a base hit in the world
series it's actually his sixth career
hit in the postseason the first hit he's
ever gotten in the world series game and
a big smile on his face right now as he
readies himself to lead off a first base
he's a stolen base threat too right yeah
nine stolen bases
and he has said he wants to get to ten
steals in the astros with their eight
and nine hitters their pitcher and their
catcher have two men on with one out
line shot out to a diving austin reilly
makes the catch out of the air
went across the foul line just behind
the bag
right across the chalk that is now
smeared across the infield dirt but a
great catch by austin probably going to
be a fair ball too it was there there'd
be some part chris conroy threw up his
left hand indicating a fair ball what a
catch by austin that saved at least one
run maybe two they will put him on and
face zach
a normal hitting pitcher you'd feel
pretty good about this but greinke
about the best hitting pitcher of the
last 15 years in the big leagues off
speed pitch grounded up the middle
albie's backhands has it throws to first
a little wide but he gets grinky boy he
almost threw that away freeman had to
stretch as far as he could to his left
to make the play one-on-one out for
freddie freddie's got that postseason
average of over 300.
gets one correa got him both played by
altuve correa and guriel and that ends
the bottom of the third inning no runs a
hit no errors none left we played three
we head to the top of the fourth
seven-time all-star jose altuve
outfielder's pretty deep especially in
center
in the air to deep center backing up
duval to the wall and forget about it
jose altuve lines up another home run in
this series jose altuve with a jack to
center field
second all-time in postseason home runs
altuve
moved out of a tie for second
with bernie williams and only manny
ramirez with four postseason home runs
than jose altuve with 29. 77th playoff
game for altuve has an ops of 9 18. two
nothing houston bottom of the fourth
runner at first one down open stance
from the left side curveball off the end
of the back could be two altuve to
correa on the first double play
there you go
zach grinky four innings at work his
second double play and that'll end the
threat
for the atlanta parade and the astros
will move on to
six foot four thirty-year-old ryan
stanek who's been a big part of this
astros bullpen in october
braves have had one hit per inning
they've not had more than one base
runner per inning
that is in there for strike three frozen
with the slider and the inning is over
tonight
major league baseball joins our partners
stand up to cancer
in reaffirming our commitment to fight
against cancer
and as we come together again in small
gatherings or in full ballparks
we remain united in our determination to
defeat this disease
please join major league baseball
mastercard
fox and the entire baseball family as we
stand together in the fight against
cancer back to the top of the order to
eddie rosario who's one for two of the
single
and rosario pulls one to the corner
and it hops up against the wall
heading for two and stopping there
a one-out double for eddie rosario and
for the first time tonight the braves
have a man in scoring position a one-out
double by rosario and he's fired up
standing on the bag out of second phil
maton on to try to put out the fire
braves have first and second first real
threat of the night one out ozzy albie's
due up swing and a miss got him on a
high fastball two outs probably swung at
ball four but the scouting report true
for the astros they know on three two
he will expand up in the zone
and maitan got it right where he wanted
it so two out still two and on for
atlanta and now austin reilly to the
plate swung on it out to left field
that'll drop in for a base hit here
comes eddie rosario the throw from
alvarez is going to be cut off short of
the plane throw to second base austin is
in there
freddie standing at third
riley comes through and it's a 2-1 ball
game
oh man he got clutch again it was a
slider
he ripped it
alvarez came up throwing but there was
no cutoff man down bases empty for
dansby swanson two one ball game in the
bottom of the seven into the air to deep
right field this one's heading back
towards the wall this ball is good
a tie game
it's tied up on a solo homer by dansby
swanson they went the other way with
power
and sent one soaring into the chop house
the marietta georgia native delivers
on an 02 pitch that is power
from the eighth spot in the lineup well
that's how you get out of trouble you
get yourself in trouble a couple of wild
swings
he's still hunting a fastball and he
gets one
center cut and he drives it to right
field the power's kind of been gone from
dansby for the last week to 10 days but
this is what he did during the regular
season
tied at two in the bottom of the seventh
as it well deep left field back there
towards the wall alvarez leaps and that
is that is out of the ballpark that is
gone
double trouble back to back dansby and
jorge had a 3-2 lead in the bottom of
the seventh for the atlanta braves
that just didn't clear the wall into the
astros bullpen
and this place is pulsing with energy
range lead for the first time tonight
it's three to two here in the seventh
ben hunt get out of here
down here
and now back to the top of the order to
jose altuve
and he hits one in the air to left
back at the wall
by rosario
right at the wall
it is eddie rosario's world man what a
catch
then he went right back to the wall
leap right there at the wall made the
catch and then they went into the
padding
took his fist and was pounding it on his
chest after he just picked up out number
three this will be your don alvarez he's
got to be careful with him round ball
rolling up the line at first freddie's
got it takes it to the bag braves win
the atlanta braves have just taken game
for the world series and they are one
win away from their first world series
title since 1995.
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes